ah oui ah oui
[Musique]
50000 francs tu as retrouvé le changeur
de Valenciennes j'ai jamais corrompu
personne
c'est pas juste quand même contre le PSG
ce soir c'est le peuple contre les
élites parisiennes le ministre Bernard
Tapie a présenté sa démission à Pierre
Bérégovoy
ez au gouvernement j'ai l'impression que
tout part en veille vous avez une grande
gueule
de l'énergie vous êtes un gagneur
Bernard tapisode
top générique c'est l'histoire d'un
petit cadeau devenu l'homme d'affaires
préféré des Français l'acquisition
d'Adidas Bernard Tapie devenue légende
tu veux venir un grand capitaine
d'industrie pour rester un petit patron
du lait par ses ouvriers tapis
souvenez-vous bien de ce nom parce qu'il
y aura un avant après
comment on fait pour reprendre une
entreprise avec ça avec ça je peux
conquérir la France
[Musique]